Passez quatre mois à vous balader en réfléchissant à trois souhaits,
petit à petit vos idées commencent à s'organiser.
Tout le monde devrait essayer -- dites-vous que vous avez droit à trois souhaits.
Que feriez-vous? C'est un très bon exercice
qui vous permet de vous recentrer sur ce qui vous tient vraiment à cœur,
et de poser un regard neuf sur le monde qui vous entoure.
Avec cette pensée, est-ce que quelqu'un, même seul, peut faire quelque chose,
peut mettre en œuvre une idée
qui parvienne à faire bouger les choses de manière visible ?
Inspiré par la nature -- voici mon thème.
Il me semble, pour être tout-à-fait honnête, que c'est là que tout a commencé pour moi.
Je me suis très vite intéressé aux paysages ; au Canada,
on a le Grand Nord, une population plutôt réduite,
mon père était un homme d'extérieur, un vrai.
Du coup j'ai pu profiter de tout ça pleinement.
Je n'ai jamais vraiment bien compris pourquoi ni comment tout ça me parlait.
Je pense que ça me rappelait
simplement à quel point nous sommes éphémères.
La nature tout autour de moi -- les côtes sauvages,
les forêts vierges que je contemplais --
tout cela donnait une idée de ce temps géologique,
du travail de longue haleine mis en œuvre
que nous ressentons d'une manière différente.
Tout ceci représentait pour moi un point de référence dont j'avais besoin,
pour pouvoir accomplir ce travail.
Et en effet, je suis sorti, j'ai pris cette photo de pousses d'herbe qui percent au printemps,
au bord d'une route.
La renaissance de l'herbe. Puis j'ai passé plusieurs années,
à photographier des paysages immaculés.
Mais, en tant que photographe artistique, j'ai senti
que ça ne marcherait pas --
que j'aurais du mal à en faire une carrière artistique.
Je me sentais enfermé dans le domaine de la photo de calendrier,
ou quelque chose du genre, dont je n'arriverais pas à m'éloigner.
C'est pourquoi je me suis mis à essayer de repenser les paysages.
Repenser les paysages comme
des paysages que nous avons transformés.
J'ai eu une sorte d'illumination alors que j'étais perdu en Pennsylvanie ;
j'avais pris à gauche en pensant que je retomberais sur l'autoroute,
et j'ai fini dans une ville nommée Frackville.
Je suis descendu de ma voiture; je me tenais
au beau milieu d'une ville minière. J'ai fait un tour sur moi-même,
et le paysage s'est transformé sous mes yeux en quelque chose de complètement surréaliste.
Entièrement transformé par l'homme.
Cela m'a décidé à aller à la recherche d'autres mines dans ce genre-là,
d'aller à la recherche des intrusions industrielles dans nos paysages
les plus impressionnantes possibles.
C'est devenu la base de mon travail,
en même temps qu'un thème dans lequel je pouvais me retrouver
sans avoir à me réinventer.
Ce sujet est si vaste qu'il peut largement occuper ma vie tout entière --
qu'il peut devenir une chose à laquelle me consacrer
en recherchant, en pistant ces industries.
Une des choses que je tenais absolument à dire lors de mes remerciements,
et que j'ai apparemment oublié de mentionner,
je voudrais remercier toutes les sociétés qui m'ont ouvert leur porte.
Presque chaque photo est le résultat de négociations
menées en vue de prendre ces clichés.
Sans l'aide de ces personnes à la tête de ces sociétés
qui m'ont laissé entrer,
je n'aurais jamais pu accomplir ce travail.
Aussi, je tiens à préciser que je ne suis pas contre les compagnies.
J'en possède une. Je travaille main dans la main avec elles,
je pense que nous en avons tous besoin, et qu'elles sont importantes.
Mais je suis également pour un développement durable.
Je me retrouve donc coincé au milieu, tiraillé entre ces deux options.
Je n'accuse personne de ce qui est en train de se passer,
mais c'est une lente dégradation.
Je me suis dit, eh bien, nous vivons à la fois toutes ces périodes :
l'Age de pierre, l'Age de Fer, l'Age de Cuivre.
Ces périodes sont bel et bien encore présentes de nos jours ;
c'est juste que nous nous sommes totalement coupés d'elles.
Il y a quelque chose qui échappe à notre regard.
C'en est presque effrayant. Une fois que l'on commence à s'intéresser
au rêve collectif de nos modes de vie,
et aux conséquences que ça occasionne sur nos paysages --
je suis parfaitement lucide quant à cette prise de conscience.
A travers mes photographies,
j'espère être capable d'entraîner mon public à ma suite,
de l'amener à cette prise de conscience, plutôt que de se détourner rapidement de l'image.
Non pas de dire "Mais qu'est-ce-que ça peut bien être ?", mais bien de s'interroger à son sujet.
De dire "C'est tellement beau à première vue.
Mais en y réfléchissant bien, c'est horrible. Je ne devrais pas m'extasier."
Comme un plaisir défendu. Je pense que c'est cette idée de plaisir défendu
qui fait boule de neige un peu partout,
qui force les gens à regarder de plus près toutes ces choses,
qui les invite à s'y attarder. C'est comme ça que je le ressens, personnellement.
Je veux mener une vie confortable,
avec une maison, une voiture ;
mais tout ça n'est pas dépourvu de conséquences.
Comment ai-je commencé à éprouver cette attraction-répulsion ?
C'est quelque chose qui me vient du plus profond de ma conscience,
et que j'essaie de reproduire dans mon travail.
Voici ce que j'ai photographié -- cette pile de pneus,
45 millions en tout. C'était la plus grosse.
Elle se trouvait à peine à une heure et demie de route de chez moi. Elle a pris feu
il y a à peu près quatre ans. Pas loin de Modesto et Westley, en Californie.
C'est comme ça que j'ai décidé de me mettre à la recherche de quelque chose qui, pour moi --
si mon travail précédent sur la manière de regarder nos paysages
était davantage l'expression d'un regret par rapport à notre action envers la nature,
le travail de recyclage que vous voyez ici, lui,
indiquait une direction. Pour moi, il s'agit de notre rédemption.
Dans mon travail de récupération,
je suis à la recherche d'une occupation -- une activité humaine qui soit durable.
Si nous continuons à mettre, grâce à notre existence industrielle et urbaine,
les objets à nouveau en circulation,
si nous continuons -- nous pourrons survivre.
Bien sûr, lorsqu'on écoute des conférences,
un tas de choses est en train d'arriver. Le bio-mimétisme,
et plein d'autres choses sont en train d'être mises en service --
les nanotechnologies, qui pourraient nous aider à
ne pas détruire ces paysages de l'intérieur.
Nous sommes tous impatients quant à ces avancées.
Mais en attendant, les choses empirent,
elles continuent sur leur lancée.
Ici, vous voyez -- je suis allé au Bangladesh,
je me suis éloigné du continent nord-américain.
J'ai commencé à regarder notre monde dans sa totalité.
Et ces images-là -- celles du Bangladesh --
ont vu le jour grâce à une émission de radio que j'écoutais.
C'était une émission sur Exxon Valdez,
qui parlait de l'inévitable surplus à venir en matière de pétroliers,
du fait des compagnies d'assurances.
Qui disait aussi que ces pétroliers allaient devoir être mis hors-service,
et que 2004 serait probablement l'année la plus chargée.
Je me suis dit, "Ça alors, c'est vraiment quelque chose à voir !"
Voir les plus grands bateaux jamais construits par l'homme, démantelés
à mains nues, littéralement, dans les pays du Tiers-Monde.
A la base, je devais aller en Inde.
Mais j'ai interdit d'entrer à cause d'un problème qu'ils avaient avec Greenpeace,
du coup je me suis tourné vers le Bangladesh.
J'ai découvert le Tiers-Monde, j'en ai vu ce que
jamais je n'aurais cru possible de voir.
130 millions de gens vivant sur un territoire de la taille du Wisconsin,
des gens partout, une pollution intense,
et des conditions de travail terribles.
Ici, ce sont des champs de pétrole en Californie,
parmi les plus vastes. Encore une fois, je me suis mis à penser que --
une autre prise de conscience pour moi --
que ce monde dans lequel je vivais était construit
sur la base d'une abondante réserve de pétrole.
Je me suis mis à réfléchir, à construire sur cette idée,
que je n'ai plus lâchée.
C'est une série que j'espère être en mesure d'achever
d'ici deux à trois ans, à peu près,
je l'ai nommée "La fête du Pétrole".
Parce que pour moi, tout ce à quoi on touche --
nos vêtements, nos voitures, nos routes, absolument tout -- en découle directement.
J'enchaîne avec des photos sur la Chine.
Avec la Chine -- j'ai commencé à y prendre des photos il y a quatre ans,
la Chine pose vraiment la question de développement durable pour moi.
Sans parler de la façon dont elle a joué sur
les industries près desquelles j'ai grandi.
Je suis né dans une ville ouvrière,
une ville General Motors ; mon père y travaillait.
Du coup je suis très proche de ce genre d'industries,
et ça se ressent dans mon travail. Mais vous savez,
voir la Chine et la vitesse à laquelle elle se développe, c'est vraiment quelque chose.
Ce que vous voyez là est le Barrage des Trois Gorges,
de 50% le plus grand barrage jamais construit par l'homme.
La plupart des ingénieurs du monde entier ont quitté le projet
pour la raison suivante : "C'est bien trop grand".
En fait, quand la zone prévue fut inondée il y a de ça un an et demi,
on a pu mesurer une hésitation dans la rotation terrestre.
Il a fallu 15 jours pour remplir le lac artificiel,
un réservoir de 600 kilomètres de long,
l'un des plus grands jamais construits.
Une autre dimension de ce projet titanesque a été
de déplacer 13 grandes villes en dehors de la zone d'inondation,
et d'abattre toutes les constructions pour qu'elles ne gênent pas les bateaux.
Avant et après. Là c'est avant.
Et là, 10 semaines plus tard, tout a été démoli à la main.
Je crois qu'ils n'ont utilisé de la dynamite que pour 11 bâtiments,
tout le reste s'est fait à la main. Voilà le résultat, 10 semaines plus tard.
Cela vous donne une bonne idée.
Là encore -- et c'était ceux-là même qui avaient habité ces maisons
qui les détruisaient à présent,
payés à la brique pour mettre à bas ce qui avait été leur ville.
En voici quelques images.
J'ai fait à peu près trois voyages aux Trois Gorges
pour contempler cette transformation massive d'un paysage.
Ça ressemble à un champ de bataille, mais ça n'en est pas un.
En fait, il s'agit d'un paysage voulu, pensé.
Ils ont besoin d'énergie, et ils sont prêts à en passer par ce genre de
transformation majeure, à cette échelle, pour en obtenir.
Là encore, c'est un vrai soulagement, en ce sens où aujourd'hui, en Chine,
ce qui est en jeu à mon avis,
c'est la construction de 27 centrales nucléaires.
Pas une seule n'a été ouverte ces 20 dernières années en Amérique du Nord,
à cause du mouvement PDMJ -- pas dans mon jardin.
Mais voilà ce qu'ils disent en Chine "Non, nous allons en ouvrir 27 au cours des 10 prochaines années".
Les chaudières à charbon font partie du lot,
il s'en ouvre littéralement toutes les semaines, tant il faut d'énergie hydroélectrique.
Le charbon est sans nul doute un des problèmes majeurs.
Une autre des conséquences de ce Barrage des Trois Gorges a été
la perte de nombre de terres agricoles, que vous voyez là, à gauche.
Des terres parmi les plus fertiles ont ainsi été englouties.
A un moment, deux millions de personnes ont été déplacées
selon les statistiques que vous prenez.
Et ça c'est ce qui a été reconstruit :
Wushan, une des plus grosses villes à avoir été déplacée.
Voici le quartier général de l'administration, c'est-à-dire la mairie de la ville.
Encore la reconstruction de la ville. Ce qui m'a fait de la peine,
c'est qu'ils n'avaient pas compris grand'chose
à ce que nous appelons la planification urbaine.
Pas de parcs, aucun espace vert.
Une forte densité de population empilée à flanc de colline.
Ils avaient là l'occasion rêvée de tout recommencer à zéro,
mais quelque part on ne partage pas les mêmes priorités.
Sur ce panneau il est écrit : "Respectez le planning familial.
Développez la science. Une idée moderne et avancée du mariage et de la naissance."
Si vous regardez cette affiche,
elle comporte tous les stéréotypes de la culture occidentale.
Vous avez les smokings, les bouquets.
Mais ce qui me fait vraiment peur dans cette image,
dans ce panneau publicitaire, c'est la raffinerie à l'arrière-plan.
C'est comme mélanger tout ce qui relève de notre culture,
c'est une adaptation de nos modes de vie, point à la ligne.
Et, à nouveau, quand vous voyez ce genre de confusion,
quand vous les voyez passer d'un mode de vie rural
avec très peu d'impact sur l'environnement, à un mode de vie urbain
avec une impact bien plus conséquent, ça vous donne sérieusement à réfléchir.
Voici une photo d'une des plus grandes places de Guangdong
qui accueille beaucoup de travailleurs migrants ayant quitté leur campagne.
On parle de migrations atteignant les 130 millions de personnes,
essayant de rallier les grandes métropoles.
Dans les 10, 15 ans à venir, ce sont des migrations
de 400 à 500 millions qui sont attendues,
vers les centres urbains tels que Shanghai et les zones de fabrication.
Les fabricants sont --
en général, les fabricants locaux -- vous pouvez deviner si une usine est locale
si les ouvriers ont des uniformes de la même couleur.
Dans cette usine, l'uniforme est rose. C'est une usine de chaussures.
Ils fournissent des dortoirs pour leurs ouvriers.
Ils les récupèrent dans leur campagne, et ils les installent dans ces dortoirs.
C'est une des plus grosses usines de chaussures, l'usine Yuyuan,
près de Shenzhen. 90 000 employés y fabriquent des chaussures.
Là, c'est un roulement d'équipes, il y en a trois par jour. A chacun d'entre eux --
il y a deux usines de cette taille dans la même ville.
Celle-là emploie 45 000 ouvriers. Tous les midis,
pas loin de 12 000 personnes viennent manger.
Ils s'asseyent, ils ont à peu près 20 minutes.
Et l'équipe suivante prend la relève. Une force de travail inimaginable
est en train de se constituer. Shanghai --
je m'intéresse au renouvellement urbain de Shanghai,
cette zone va être entièrement rasée
et plantée de gratte-ciels en cinq ans.
Mais ce qu'on voit aussi apparaître à Shanghai --
cela veut dire que la Chine est en train de changer, car rien de la sorte n'existait
ne serait-ce que cinq ans auparavant. Voici un irréductible.
En chinois, on les appelle "dingzihu" -- des clous rivés au sol.
Ils refusent de s'en aller. Ils refusent de négocier.
Comme on ne leur offre pas assez, ils refusent de partir.
Du coup, ils ne lâchent pas tant qu'on ne leur offre pas de meilleur marché.
On peut dire que ça leur réussit plutôt bien,
quand on les compare à ceux qui se sont fait expulser sans ménagement.
Ils se font mettre à la porte en deux heures de temps --
des communautés présentes depuis des centaines d'années,
peut-être même des milliers d'années,
se retrouvent éparpillées dans des banlieues lointaines
à l'extérieur de Shanghai. Mais tous ces gens-là, eux, tiennent bon
face à cette reconstruction de Shanghai.
Il s'agit probablement du plus vaste projet de renouvellement urbain
jamais mis en œuvre sur cette planète.
Mais ce par quoi ils souhaitent remplacer tout ça --
une fois de plus, un de mes vœux, que je n'ai jamais osé leur avouer,
serait de leur faire comprendre qu'il y a de meilleures manières de construire une maison.
Les conflits entre les différents styles et matériaux étaient vraiment intéressants,
là vous avez les villas.
Et aussi, comme vous pouvez le voir, ils sont sur le point de s'en aller.
Les échafaudages sont encore là, ici c'est une zone de déchets électroniques,
et si vous regardez bien, au premier plan,
vous pouvez voir quelle est leur industrie -- le recyclage.
Ces industries sont déjà en train de se développer
dans ces nouveaux quartiers.
Vous voyez ici un pont à cinq étages, à Shanghai.
Shanghai est une ville très curieuse -- elle est en pleine explosion,
comme aucune ville n'en a jamais fait l'expérience, je pense.
En fait, même Shenzhen, dont la zone industrielle, ou économique --
l'une des toutes premières -- comptait environ 100 000 habitants il y a 15 ans,
se targue d'en compter 10 à 11 millions aujourd'hui.
Cela vous donne une idée de l'échelle et de la vitesse de ces migrations --
là ce sont les taxis produits par Volkswagen.
Quelques 9000 véhicules,
construits pour l'usage des grandes villes comme
Pékin, Shanghai, Shenzhen.
Ce n'est même pas le marché automobile intérieur, mais celui des taxis.
Ce que vous voyez là est particulier aux constructions de banlieue --
dans la même veine, sauf qu'il s'agit là de tours.
Ils en construisent 20, 40 en même temps,
et elles poussent de la même manière
que le ferait une de nos maisons particulières.
La densité est également assez incroyable.
Une des choses que je tenais à souligner dans cette image
est le fait que, en voyant ce genre de constructions,
j'ai eu un choc en m'apercevant
qu'ils ne disposaient pas d'une climatisation centralisée.
Chaque fenêtre est pourvue de son climatiseur.
Je suis persuadé qu'il y a ici des gens qui en savent
plus que moi sur l'efficacité énergétique,
mais j'ai du mal à imaginer qu'un climatisateur par appartement puisse
refroidir efficacement un bâtiment de cette taille.
Quand vous commencez à y prêter attention,
puis à factoriser cela à la taille d'une ville comme Shanghai,
c'est une véritable forêt de gratte-ciels.
C'est tout simplement ahurissant, en termes de vitesse à laquelle cette ville se transforme.
Au premier plan de cette image, vous voyez
un des derniers quartiers abritant ces irréductibles.
Aujourd'hui, tout a été rasé -- c'est une photo qui date de près de 8 mois,
à la place, des gratte-ciels fleurissent à cet endroit précis.
Un gratte-ciel se construit en une nuit, littéralement, à Shanghai.
Plus récemment, je me suis intéressé
aux plus grosses industries chinoises.
Vous avez ici Baosteel, juste à côté de Shanghai.
Voici la réserve de charbon pour l'usine de production d'acier -- 18 km².
C'est une opération gigantesque, quelque chose comme 15 000 ouvriers,
cinq coupoles, et une sixième en cours de construction ici.
Ils sont en train de mettre sur pied d'immenses hauts fourneaux
afin de faire face à la demande intérieure pressante.
Voici trois des hauts fourneaux visibles sous cet angle.
Encore une fois, sur ces images, vous voyez flotter constamment une espèce de brume.
Cette vidéo, en temps réel, va vous montrer le travail d'un assembleur sur un disjoncteur.
10 heures par jour à cette vitesse.
Pour moi, l'un des problèmes que nous
avons avec la Chine
est qu'ils ont beaucoup recours à des technologies de production de pointe.
Sur cette photo, vous avez 400 employés en train de travailler.
J'ai demandé au manager de me désigner cinq parmi les plus rapides,
puis je suis allé les observer 15 à 20 minutes chacun,
avant de choisir cette femme.
Elle était rapide comme l'éclair,
je n'arrivais pas à en croire mes yeux.
Mais l'astuce qui leur permet de
gagner aujourd'hui, c'est qu'ils se servent
des dernières technologies, de machines d'extrusion,
pour obtenir tous les éléments nécessaires,
et c'est en fait l'assemblage qui les fait gagner --
leurs travailleurs migrants sont prêts à travailler. Ils veulent travailler.
Ils ont une réserve impressionnante de gens à la recherche de ce genre d'emploi.
C'est un état de fait qui va durer encore 10 ou 15 ans,
s'ils font ce qu'ils veulent faire, c'est-à-dire
entre 400 et 500 millions de gens affluant vers les villes.
Dans ce cas-là -- ça c'est la ligne de montage que vous avez vue,
et en voici un cliché.
J'ai dû avoir recours à une très petite ouverture pour rendre la profondeur.
J'ai du leur demander de se figer pendant 10 secondes pour prendre cette photo.
J'ai dû m'y reprendre à cinq reprises,
car ils ne pouvaient pas s'arrêter. Les ralentir était réellement impossible.
Ils étaient comme des automates répétant sans cesse les mêmes gestes,
jusqu'au moment où le manager leur a dit d'une voix sévère
"Bon, on ne bouge plus."
Ce n'était pas si mal,
mais ils sont censés produire ces choses à un rythme incroyable.
Voici une fabrique de soie synthétique, un dérivé du pétrole.
Ce que vous voyez là est bel et bien
à nouveau, une fabrique dernier cri,
avec 500 machines valant environ chacune 200 000 dollars.
Quelques douze employés y travaillent,
ils ne font qu'inspecter -- passer dans les allées.
Les machines fonctionnent toutes,
c'est tout simplement impressionnant de voir la taille de ces industries.
Aussi je me suis allé de plus en plus profond dans ces usines.
Il s'agit ici d'un diptyque, j'en fais beaucoup afin
de donner une idée des dimensions de ces endroits.
Voici une ligne où ils récupèrent les fils
et les enroulent ensemble,
avant de les envoyer vers les usines de textiles.
Là, vous avez un travail bien plus intensif,
la production de chaussures.
Ce niveau compte à peu près 1500 travailleurs.
La compagnie en compte 10 000 au total,
et ils produisent des chaussures pour le marché intérieur.
Ç'a été très dur de visiter des sociétés internationales,
parce qu'il me fallait la permission de sociétés comme Nike ou Adidas,
ce qui n'était pas chose aisée.
Ils ne veulent pas de moi chez eux.
Par contre, c'était bien plus facile avec les entreprises locales.
Ça vous donne vraiment un sens de -- c'est à ce niveau-là,
précisément, que commencèrent la grande migration des emplois vers la Chine,
et la production de chaussures. Nike a été l'un des premiers.
Et, réellement -- une telle force de travail,
la démarche de profiter de ce marché du travail était tout à fait sensée.
Voici un portable nouvelle génération, un téléphone Bird,
un des plus gros fabricants de portables en Chine.
Je crois qu'il se crée de nouvelles compagnies de portables
quasiment chaque semaine,
il y a une croissance exponentielle dans ce domaine.
Là c'est une usine où ils font des chemises.
Youngor, la plus grosse usine de vêtements et de chemises en Chine.
Sur cette photo vous pouvez voir une de leurs cantines.
Tout est très efficace.
Lors de l'installation de mon matériel pour la photo,
les ouvriers passaient en moyenne entre 8 et 10 minutes à déjeuner.
C'est une des plus grosses usines que j'ai visitées.
Ils y produisent des cafetières, le plus gros producteur,
et des fers à repasser.
Ils en produisent 20 millions de par le monde.
21 000 employés travaillent pour eux. Cette usine -- et il y a plusieurs --
fait 500 mètres de long.
Ce sont des photos récentes -- je suis revenu il y a à peine un mois,
vous êtes les premiers à poser les yeux sur
ces nouvelles photos d'usines.
Ça m'a pris presqu'un an pour arriver à avoir accès à ces endroits.
Un autre aspect de ce qui est en train de se passer en Chine
se situe au niveau de son besoin urgent de matériaux.
Beaucoup des matériaux recyclés que l'on collecte ici
sont d'abord recyclés puis envoyés par bateau en Chine.
Là c'est du métal en cube. Ici, des armatures électriques,
des moteurs électriques dont ils récupèrent
le cuivre et l'acier de qualité pour les recycler.
C'est très certainement en lien avec la Californie et la Silicon Valley.
Enfin voilà ce qui arrive à la majorité de nos ordinateurs.
50% de la totalité des ordinateurs finissent par être recyclés en Chine.
Tout cela est qualifié de déchets électroniques.
Ce qui pose un léger problème. La manière dont ils recyclent les cartes électroniques,
par exemple, ils se servent des briquettes de charbon
qu'on trouve partout en Chine, pour les chauffer,
et en extraire les composants à l'aide de pinces.
Ils essaient de récupérer les métaux précieux contenus dans ces composants.
Mais les émanations toxiques -- quand vous entrez dans une ville qui
a recours à ce genre de procédé,
vous pouvez le sentir de 5 à 10 km avant d'être arrivé.
Là, vous avez autre chose. Ce sont des industries artisanales,
donc plus petites -- ils brûlent ces cartes électroniques sur leurs porches,
dans leurs cours, voire à l'intérieur de leurs maisons.
Au cas où quelqu'un passerait par là --
c'est une activité illégale en Chine,
mais ils ne peuvent empêcher les produits d'arriver.
Ce portrait -- je n'en fais pas beaucoup,
mais je n'ai pas pu résister à celui-ci, elle a survécu à Mao,
au Grand Bond en Avant,
à la Révolution Culturelle, et aujourd'hui elle est assise devant sa maison,
avec ce dépôt de déchets électroniques à côté. Pas banal.
Là vous voyez une route qui a été consolidée par des cartes électroniques
dans une des plus grosses villes vivant du recyclage.
Voilà pour les photos que je voulais vous montrer.
(Applaudissements)
Je voudrais dédier mes vœux à mes deux filles.
Elles étaient toujours présentes à mon esprit alors que je réfléchissais à tout ça.
L'une d'elle s'appelle Megan, à droite, l'autre c'est Katja.
Pour moi ce concept tout entier --
mes photos témoignent du souci que je me fais quant à
la taille de notre développement, et sa définition.
Il y a un tas de bonnes choses qui nous attendent --
c'est palpable dans cette salle --
qui sont sur le point d'être inventées
et qui résoudront bien des problèmes,
j'espère sincèrement qu'elles seront diffusées de par le monde,
et commenceront à produire un effet positif.
Ce n'est pas seulement une influence sur notre monde,
mais quelque chose qui commence à grandir -- je suis sûr que nous pouvons commencer à agir
sur notre empreinte écologique, la réduire -- cette empreinte, en Asie,
croît de manière extrêmement rapide,
et je ne crois pas que nous puissions la contrebalancer. En dernier recours, la stratégie
serait, d'après moi, d'observer de très près son évolution.
En ce qu'elle est liée intimement à la nôtre.
C'est à la fois un souhait et une pensée réfléchie :
prenons le temps de réfléchir à tout cela,
posons-nous la question :
"Qu'est-ce qui se passera quand ils voudront avoir des enfants,
quand ils voudront se marier, dans 20 ans --
ou même 15 ans ?"
C'est principalement ce qui est à la base de toutes mes réflexions,
de mon travail, et cette chance incroyable d'exprimer des vœux.
Premier vœu : changer le monde. Je veux me servir de mes photos
pour convaincre des millions de gens d'engager une discussion mondiale sur le développement durable.
Grâce aux formes de communication d'aujourd'hui,
je suis convaincu que c'est chose possible.
Oh, et je me suis mis à la recherche -- je voulais raccrocher
mon idée à quelque chose. Je ne voulais pas d'un vœu venant de nulle part.
L'un d'eux ne se rattache à rien de concret, mais celui-ci,
je voulais découvrir ce qui marchait déjà actuellement.
Worldchanging.com est un blog fantastique,
qui est consulté par près de 500000 visiteurs par mois.
Il a été créé il y a un peu plus d'un an,
et ce que j'ai trouvé beau
c'est que le ton de la conversation est celui qui me convient.
On n'y parle pas de --
là où le mouvement écologique a échoué à mes yeux,
c'est dans son recours systématique au bâton,
aux discours apocalyptiques.
Il n'a jamais essayé de mettre en avant les aspects positifs
qu'il peut y avoir à être écolo, à s'engager dans cette voie-là,
alors que ce blog-là ne parle quasiment
que de ça,
de savoir comment améliorer notre planète, le plus vite possible.
Il s'intéresse aux technologies, aux nouveaux dispositifs d'économie d'énergie,
à comment repenser, définir de nouvelles stratégies pour
un développement durable.
J'ai donc pensé à me servir
de mon travail pour promouvoir
ce site, Worldchanging.com.
Comme vous le savez peut-être, c'est un membre de TED -- Stephen Sagmeister et moi-même
travaillons ensemble sur quelques projets, mais tout ceci n'est qu'un début.
Ce n'est pas le produit fini. Mais ces images, avec Worldchanging.com,
vont pouvoir être relayées par toutes sortes de médias,
en tant que posts sur le Net,
sur des panneaux d'affichage, collées sur des abri-bus, n'importe où.
C'est ce à quoi nous sommes actuellement occupés.
Nous en sommes venus à la conclusion
que dans la plupart des médias une image est accompagnée de beaucoup de texte,
qui s'étale allègrement sur toute l'image.
D'après Stephen, ce qui est bizarre
c'est que moins de 5% des pubs ont exclusivement recours à une image.
Et c'est pourquoi,
étant donné qu'il s'agit de ces images, de ce qu'elles représentent,
des questions qu'elles posent,
on a pensé laisser ces images faire leur travail, c'est-à-dire amener les gens à penser :
"Mais qu'est-ce-que ce Worldchanging.com peut bien avoir à faire avec ces images-là ?"
et, espérons-le, les incitent à venir voir le site.
C'était Worldchanging.com, la construction du blog. Oui, c'est un blog,
et j'espère que ce ne sera pas -- pour moi ce n'est pas le genre de blog
auquel nous serons fidèles jusqu'à la mort.
C'est un blog qui va se faire remarquer, qui va sortir du lot,
et atteindre -- à l'instant où je vous parle, des débats sont lancés
en Inde, en Chine, en Amérique du Sud,
des gens de tous pays s'y retrouvent pour discuter.
Je pense que Worldchanging.com nous offre la possibilité
de mettre en place un véritable dialogue autour du développement durable.
Si vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour lui faire de la pub, ce serait merveilleux.
Mon deuxième vœu part d'une base plus concrète, plus locale.
Il s'agit de mettre en place une nouvelle forme de compétition
qui motive nos enfants à réfléchir, à inventer sur le développement durable.
Ce qui en est ressorti --
Allison, à qui d'ailleurs je dois ma nomination, a fait remarquer
dans une de nos réunions précédentes, qu'au Canada
le recyclage était promu avec succès par les enfants âgés de 9 à 12 ans.
Et quand on y songe,
9 ans -- pour ma femme et moi, 7 ans c'est l'âge de raison,
donc ça c'est acquis. Et ce n'est pas encore la puberté.
Ils sont dans une phase d'ouverture totale --
c'est à ce moment-là qu'il faut agir sur eux. Vous savez ce qui se passe à la puberté ?
Il y a déjà eu des présentations là-dessus.
Donc ce que je voudrais réussir à faire, c'est motiver ces enfants
à rapporter ces idées chez eux, à assimiler ce qu'est le développement durable,
et qu'ils ont un intérêt direct à ce qu'il se réalise.
L'une des manières d'agir est d'utiliser cette récompense,
je vais garder 30 à 40 000 dollars,
et tout le reste va aller à la réalisation de ce projet.
A la mise en place de récompenses destinées aux enfants.
C'est l'autre chose que je voulais à tout prix créer --
ces prix-cibles.
On pourrait en attribuer à ceux ayant eu l'idée la plus écologique
dans un cadre scolaire, et dans un cadre familial,
et dans un cadre communautaire.
J'ai aussi pensé que ça serait un prix sympa
que d'élire la meilleure création artistique "In My World". Et ce qui pourrait se passer --
est évolutif. Si on arrive à encourager les gens à investir --
que ce soit dans des équipements, comme un labo,
ou simplement de l'argent, qui donne de l'importance aux récompenses --
si on arrive à étendre ce projet à l'ensemble des écoles publiques,
ou des écoles avec des enfants de cet âge-là,
et à mettre en place une compétition ouverte à tous
avec ces récompenses à la clé.
Un prix ne sera attribué que si l'idée est réalisable, et pas seulement une idée.
La dimension artistique s'intéressera aux idées elles-mêmes, comment elles présentent,
comment elles fonctionnent, mais elles doivent avant tout être réalisables.
Ce que nous essayons de faire ici, c'est
de pousser une certaine génération à se mettre à réfléchir.
Ils vont diffuser cette réflexion partout -- par exemple,
dans leurs familles. Les parents y réagiront,
en aidant leurs enfants à réaliser leurs projets.
Tout ça va, d'après moi, porter le sujet du développement durable
d'une manière extrêmement positive,
et éduquer les gens. On est habitué au recyclage désormais,
mais on ne pense pas vraiment au développement durable dans toutes nos actions,
ni à notre empreinte énergétique, et leur importance.
Les éduquer, à mes yeux, serait un vœu fantastique,
une cause pour laquelle je suis certainement prêt à m'investir.
Une fois de plus, dans la compétition "In My World" --
on pourrait utiliser les œuvres d'art qui y participent pour promouvoir tout ça.
J'aime beaucoup le nom "In My World",
parce qu'il donne à chaque participant la possession du monde.
C'est mon monde, pas celui de quelqu'un d'autre, et je veux lui offrir mon aide.
Je veux en faire quelque chose. Pour moi, c'est une chance unique
de libérer les imaginations -- de bonnes idées viennent des enfants --
de faire travailler leurs imaginations en vue d'un projet concret,
et de venir en aide aux écoles.
Je pense que toutes les écoles sauraient utiliser des matériels ou de l'argent en plus --
ça ne pourrait que les encourager dans cette direction-là.
Voilà quelques idées sur comment promouvoir
le projet "In My World".
Mon troisième vœu serait un film Imax. On m'a dit que je devrais en faire un moi-même,
et l'idée d'être associé à un tel projet m'a toujours paru intéressante.
A l'échelle de mon travail, au vu des idées qui me tiennent à cœur --
la première fois que j'ai vu un film Imax, je me suis tout de suite dit :
"Il y a une réelle résonance entre ce que j'essaye de faire,
et la portée de mon travail en tant que photographe".
Je pense que c'est le moyen de créer quelque chose de puissant --
de toucher un public nouveau, pour peu que j'en aie l'occasion.
Je suis toujours à la recherche d'un mentor, vraiment. Je viens de fêter mon anniversaire,
j'ai 50 ans, je ne suis plus en âge de retourner à l'école --
j'ai trop de travail. C'est pourquoi j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
qui puisse m'enseigner tout ce dont j'ai besoin de savoir en accéléré,
qui puisse me guider à travers ce labyrinthe.
Ce serait fantastique. Voilà pour mes trois souhaits.
(Applaudissements)